[Music]
[Applause]
he's nick wright first things first
co-host
just back from italy there were you
recognized in italy
six times
not that i was counting oh okay
okay including from a great service
member who lives over there
a guy who was in from paris
in italy came over and said he watches
from paris yeah dan
i mean you know the show's international
the podcast is growing as well you never
promote that you just promote the tv
show because you don't want more audio
competitors but you can also get the
podcast what's right show me and my son
uh but it's good to see you your guy
paul pabst
sent me a very nice note giving me a
restaurant recommendation when he saw i
was in italy so shout out to paulie i
was unable to reply because i didn't
have connectivity when it happened but
thank you paulie sure it's very kind of
him yeah and thank you to you because i
paid for the trip by selling that watch
video sweet oh no no i'm kidding of
course i'd never do that to you dan i
had it but you want to know something
funny
uh the day before todd texted me and
asked me to come on i had had a dream
that i was hosting this show and that
lunatic uh caller the guy who lives in
texas and hates mike mccarthy
and irving yeah that guy that i i hosted
the show and i got there and i was all
excited i was like man i'm hosting for
dan patrick
and then shayne irving was in studio and
he's like i'm hosting with you i'm like
you're hosting with me they're like yeah
i had that dream and then todd asked me
to come on the next day true story uh i
would promote the podcast if you gave us
the information to promote the podcast
because when guests come on they send
todd information hey would you promote
this
or i'm doing this
i'm not listen i'm not in the business
throwing todd under the bus i did that
once it cost me friday this is a meet
friday i when the podcast first launched
okay i gave him that information now i
not have not given it to him every time
okay uh but it's fine okay it's fine i
will promote it myself what's right joe
with a new studio
starting next week from my wife's
boutique in harlem how about that built
out a little podcast studio there it's
not quite the man cave and said it's in
a woman's boutique but still pretty dope
okay that's a double promotion that i
allowed you to have thank you i
appreciate it and shout out to your wife
all right thank you uh charles barkley
yeah deemed kevin durant mr miserable
oh
that's interesting fair
he doesn't seem happy a lot i don't know
if miserable is the way i would put it i
do you remember a couple years ago adam
silver said
that he thinks one of the big issues the
nba has is
that its superstars
seem generally unhappy and that he was
concerned about that with that mercurial
i don't know if he used that word i
would use uh it what is odd to me is
that the two guys who i would think of
that come to the immediate forefront of
that are katie and kyrie and then they
came together and i get you know i know
the phrase misery loves company i don't
know if they're miserable but i do think
kyrie
doesn't necessarily like the attention
that comes along with being a pro
athlete and hasn't reconciled in his
brain that it the with the attention is
part and parcel with the money kd on the
other hand i think is a very unique case
and that he operates it would appear and
he hates when people psychoanalyze him
so i apologize but i will do it anyway
uh
he he wants to be judged purely on
a
nothing but how good of a basketball
player are you metric and he feels like
understandably i'm an a triple plus
student in that category one of the
greatest students ever so why do i catch
so much grief and it's because
in these shows and in not just on
television and radio but in barber shops
everywhere with friends whatever group
chats we talk about how you lead a team
what type of teammate you are we we have
those conversations and kd doesn't seem
to think those are fair or like those
but that's just part of how people
consume sports i don't think it's asking
too much for you to be more than just a
great basketball player
i don't either
um
i don't need you to be my gm i don't
need you to be my coach
um but it feels like he wants to be gm
and coach but then like he he kind of
picks and chooses uh where you can
question him
uh
but it's really
i don't know i got disappointed where he
built this or was part of you know the
architecture and then he wanted out when
it got tough
but now he goes back because he has to
go back because you know there's no
trade market for him
it's a very odd situation that he
the kids would say fumbled the bag the
way he did on this we are on a decade
plus long streak the last superstar to
demand to be traded and not ultimately
get his wish was the late great kobe
bryant that was in 2007. but it was
almost 15 straight years of if a guy
demands out even a superstar ben simmons
far from a superstar he got his way he
had to wait a couple months but he got
his way and kd
kept like upping the ante up to and
including demanding the coach and gm be
fired and then didn't refute any of
those reports then there was the report
that he's contemplating retirement he
refuted that one which i think was a
strategic error because as it's why you
when you go to court they tell you if
you're going to plead the fifth you got
to plead the fifth on all of it if you
pick and choose what you're going to
answer it can get you in trouble by
refuting one report fair or not it
served as confirmation for many of the
others well you didn't refute the report
that you demanded to be traded you
didn't refute the report you wanted the
gm and head coach fired and then what my
favorite part of the end of the kd cycle
which i don't think has ended i think
it's paused i think if things go left in
brooklyn this could come up again and
the trade market could heat up again
because everyone loves their team in the
offseason but all these guys are like i
won't trade brandon ingram for kevin
durant okay a lot of the pelicans get
out slow maybe you will um but what i
found most delicious about the whole
thing was the net statement that they
released was on joint letterhead katie's
boardroom logo was on there too
partnership it's a partnership that's
what stood out unbelievable yes it's
unbelievable that they and they a
partnership up to and including the
letterhead it was a nets the boardroom
joint statement i just i i hate to bring
things back to lebron but i will for a
moment
i
one of the things that has been either
good fortune good luck or picking the
right people that has helped lebron
immensely is the group of people around
him
are brilliant at their individual fields
people can talk trash on rich paul for
how he got started
the results are undeniable he is an
effective excellent agent maverick
absent of lebron
would have tens of millions of dollars
and massive success he's a brilliant guy
those guys being his brain trust
as opposed with respect rich kleiman who
i think is a fine guy but i don't think
necessarily has the experience those
guys do i think he maybe has gotten some
bad advice along the way and what do you
do if you're steve nash
you know kyrie and kd
don't want you there but management has
backed you ownership is back to you
are you do you probably know steve a
little bit would be my guess
were you the people who know him i don't
know him
seem to think there was a chance he was
gonna just resign to say i don't i don't
need this i don't want this this is not
fun he's rich forever anyway he loves
playing tennis could have great life i
don't know because what is the iconic
steve nash image
of these two plus years in brooklyn it's
after game five against milwaukee what i
believe is durant's greatest game ever
when he played all 48 had 48 19 and 10.
after
kyrie went down hard and you know was
playing on one leg
katie wills them to a victory game i was
at actually and nash is bear hugging him
at half court after the game just a
full-on embrace and it's kind of a funny
image because katie's so much taller
than him and nash looks so appreciative
the one thing nash had going
was the relationship
and now that seems torched now the only
saving grace is
if kd went to him beforehand and said
listen man
you know i don't want to be here
i'm not blaming you but the only card i
have left to play is i'm gonna demand
they fire you i know they won't now i'm
gonna get traded it's not personal it's
you know business but even if you went
to him with that it's still humiliating
it's still something that you're not
you don't want to swallow and now he's
got to now he's got to do it
it's not like steve nash can go to the
press and say hey katie he loves me this
was just a negotiating ploy and uh you
know we're fine yeah everybody exactly
it's a tough spot it's a really tough
we're talking to nick wright first
things first co-host on fox sports one
and got a huge podcast there uh he's
gonna be at a boutique in harlem his
wife's uh boutique in harlem there you
go a meet and greet a meet and greet
we're gonna do that eventually yeah yep
not yet we don't yet have the
infrastructure for it but we will
eventually i might stop
maybe i'll stop down i would love you to
okay it'd be wonderful i it's my turn to
buy a meal maybe it's my turn there's a
good hot dog stand right down the street
i like a little street meat nothing
wrong with that
um i'll get a few things i wanted 100
125 125th
uh on the train i just get off there and
i just walk over
it's exactly right you'll be blocks away
okay that is correct
did you have something you wanted to
bring up there well there was one sports
thing and then one personal thing i
don't know if we have time for both the
sports thing is
i
there were those of us
that
doubted
chet holmgren's ability as
the skinniest player since keith kloss
the nba has seen to hold up okay and we
raised those concerns
even those of us didn't think it would
take literally one possession of
guarding lebron james for him to miss a
season
i
so here's my question for you on chat
what if you were the thunder
would be
less concerned
if
he's never cared about gaining weight
never been in a weight room never
prioritized it
or
if as his coaches and family say
he tries to gain weight he works out all
the time he's a weight room guy
and he looks like that because to me
it'd be less concerning if it was apathy
it appears it's inability his body won't
take it and that makes me incredibly
concerned
in today's nba skinny doesn't bother me
what about skinniest
skinniest
but still it's in today's nba if it was
you know a previous generation or you
know 15 years
yeah yeah yeah when when when scores
were you know in the 80s you know like
that great basketball was on display
nothing like a cavs knicks game with no
nothing like it man nick's heat back
when you know our friend jvg was holding
on to alonzo morning's leg like a rag
doll at the end of a 7168 nail fighter
all right painful okay
okay okay personal story okay because
dan arlovsky came on your show
and told an anecdote about how his
entire empire was built on fraud yeah i
think that's the short version yes okay
yeah
and in spirit of that i'm going to tell
a story publicly that i've never told
the most embarrassing moment of my
athletic life okay because i think you
will enjoy it out of a testament to our
friendship and how much i appreciate
this and the fact that i didn't know you
had an athletic life that okay to me is
the headline that's the headline okay
okay you guys saw me change that tire
with my shirt off there was no there's
no question about that once upon a time
i was an athlete so in high school i
played two sports
basketball on track loved basketball was
mediocre at it
didn't love track that much was good at
it
state final
of the 4 by 800 relay
i'm the anchor league on that team
is quentin lucas who's now the mayor of
kansas city the mayor of my hometown
i get the baton we're in
about third place
i run the first lap we're still in third
i'm about a quarter of the way through
the second lap
and i'm passed i'm like oh no we're
gonna fall off the little podium
then i'm past again
and i'm like now we're in fifth
and i
and it's like i'm running out of gas
and dan i faked a hamstring injury
i started
i ran the left i ran the last 150 meters
holding on to my left hamstring so i had
a built-in excuse for costing my team a
medal that happened oh i feel such
relief getting that off my chest did you
have a family member come out of the
stands to help you just like the kid in
the olympia no i i limped and i got
there but the thing was i didn't i
thought the metal stand was just top
three
the metal stand for the state finals top
eight you get a ribbon or something
and i would have easily still finished
top eight but i faked the injury and so
we finished second to last
paulie call the mayor of kansas city to
get a comment on this
email in yeah oh god the other two
people on the relay team is my dear
friend quint who's now the mayor my best
friend in high school jason backstrom
and my girlfriend's brother
uh eric black i let them all down
i let them all down dan
do they are they finding out about this
now yes oh my god
who was the uh the olympian whose dad
came out of the stands oh that was a
great moment that was a great moment
yeah i can see it i don't know who it
was that would have been that would have
been great if a family member came out
to help you cross the finish line fake
the hamstring injury and then didn't
know how long i had to keep up the lie
like when i go back to school the next
week do i have to like yes you still got
a limp
yes paulie that was a 92 olympics in
barcelona derrick redmond tore his hammy
into 400 meters his dad came out and
helped him across the finish line yeah
get him on see if he did the same thing
he's calling you a phony fraud
yeah so
okay
final 30 seconds
kd ben kyrie
lebron a.d russ
which trio plays more games together
this year
oh katie bin kyrie because lebron 80
russ will play zero
that trade's happening so right right
russ is going where
i don't know where he ends up i do think
that everything swirling around the
pacers is is accurate i think the lakers
are gonna end up with buddy healed and
maybe miles turner
russ maybe ends up there or it's a
three-teamer and he ends up in utah or
san antonio
i would love to get buddy healed and
miles turner if i'm i'd love you find
the lakers like okay
i like this yep like this i don't i
don't like patrick beverly but that's
either here nor there it happens i think
they did that as like a little final
salvo to russ like how
what can we do to get rid of russ how
about we bring in patrick beverly well
he can't play anymore bring him in yeah
bring him make rusco pick him up at the
airport can you imagine the disgust in
russ's face if at some point in a tight
game he were to get subbed out
i don't think it's sustainable dan i
don't
thank you nick that's not right first
things first co-host on fox sports one
and a podcast that's sweeping the world
and a boutique in harlem come and say
hello to nick and his wife